بعدك انطف العالم ما بقى بالشوارع نور احد
عمالقه الطرب الخليجي عبد الكريم عبد
القادر يغادر دنيانا عن عمر نهز الثمانيه
عام
صوت شجي فخم اطرب الملايين في الخليج
والدول العربيه لعقود من الزمن واسر
المستمعين باحساسه واحترامه لفنه بالتاكيد
ابو خالد موهبه انفجرت في الستينيات بدات
بالموشحات الدينيه صوت من اصوات الزمن
الجميل برع في مختلف الالوان الغنائيه
باختصار هو صوت الكويت اغنيته وطن النهار
التي اصبحت رمزا لتحرير البلاد في بدايه
التسعينات بعد التحرير بالفعل من جيل
الطيبين مشاهدينا خرج عبد الكريم عبد
القادر وخلال حياته حظيه بكاريزما هائله
خفت الصوت الجريح ولم يخمد الارث كبير
وبات في القلوب والذكريات
[موسيقى]
عام
هذا الشاب اليافع انضم الى الاذاعه
الكويتيه طبعا متكئ على احلام على موهبه
الغنائيه فقط شقه طريق حياتها العمليه
موظف في وزاره الداخليه قبل ان ينضم
لوزاره الاعلام في النهايه قرر الاستقاله
لمطارده شغفه وجد صوت عبد الكريم عبد
القادر طريقه لقلوب الجمهور الكويتي سريعا
الرحله بدات بالموشحات الدينيه وبعدها
اطلق تكون ظالم التي كتبت ميلاد فنان يعشق
فنه وفي عام 1988 نال لقب الصوت الجريح
بعد طرح اغنيه الايقونيه اجر صوتي او اجر
الصوت في قمه عطاء اختار الابتعاد عن
المسرح والتوقف عن الغناء في جميع الحفلات
يقول ان السبب كان اضطرار الى الاعتذار عن
حفل في بلد عربي والعوده الى الكويت بسبب
ظروف حمل زوجته وعندما اختلف مع منظمي
الحفل اتخذ قراره في التواصل مع محبيه عبر
التسجيلات تسجيلات الاستوديو فقط واخلص
لذلك التعهد حتى
رغم جماهريته الكبيره كان دائما ما يعرف
او يعرف نفسه على انه فنان غير محترف يقول
انه عاشق للفن بدون انتظار مقابل لم يقتصر
غناء عبد الكريم على لون محدد كان مواكبا
لتغير ذوق العام لكن شخصيته وحضوره طاغي
ظل مكونان لا يتجزاان في جميع اعماله سته
عقود قدم فيها عبد الكريم عبد القادر مئات
الاغاني في 47 البوم مثل فيها لحن الوطن
انستولوجيا ورافق صوته عده اجيال الفه
الاطفال في رحلتهم الى المدرسه ايضا
الكبار في سكون الليل
وما ادراك مع عشاق الليل غادر ايضا الدنيا
ليترك القلوب ملتعه في الكويت في دول
الخليج وايضا حتى في الوطن العربي
صلى عليك الله يرحمه
[موسيقى]
من الكويت ينضم الينا شاعر خالد البذال
صبحك الله بالخير عظم الله اجرك تعازينا
لك انت صديق
للفنان عبد الكريم عبد القادر وكذلك
لاسرته عزائنا انه هو دائما موجود معانا
في ذكرياتنا في حياتنا اليوميه تفضل خالد
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير اخوي عادل صبح على
اخواننا ومشاهدينا في الوطن العربي
طبعا
احنا
يعتصر قلوبنا الحزن
والعنفقدان هذا العلم اعلام الوطن العربي
الفنان الكبير عبد الكريم عبد القادر طبعا
يمكن في مقدمتكم لخصتوا يعني شيء بسيط من
مسيرته الفنيه اللي راكبه 60 عام وعاصرها
خمسه اجيال من من الاجيال اللي اللي عاشوا
على ذكريات وعلى
مشاويرهم
والامهم وافراحهم
يعني عبد الكريم كان مصاحب الجميع في في
احساسه وفي شعوره صغار وكبار رحمه الله
على ابو خالد وانا سعيد يا حبيبي في
نعم نعم يا عادل طبعا انا لي اتفضل
نظري بانه يعني رغم هذه المسيره الفنيه
العملاقه اللي امتدت لعقود من الزمن ورغم
وجوده بذاكره كل الكويتيين والخليجيين
ايضا بهذه الصوره الحرفيه الكبيره الكبيره
الا انه كان هو يوصف نفسه بانه هو محب
للفن وفنان غير محترف كمان يعني هذا اذا
يدل على شيء على تواضع
اكثر عن هذا الجانب من شخصيته استاذ خالد
شخصيته اختي الكريمه عبد الكريم عبد
القادر انا اكثر من مره قلتها هو شخصيته
اللي تسمعينها في الاغاني
والله العظيم اي شخصيته هذه انسان محب
انسان رومانسي انسان عاطفي عمري عمري ما
سمعت صوته ولا عمري شفت سمعته عصب انا 27
سنه ملازمه في المكتب
الصبح من الساعه 9:00 نداوم الى الساعه
واحده الظهر ومن الساعه اربعه العصر الى
الساعه ثم عمري ما شفته عصب ولا زعل ولا
ولا طول صوته ولا شيء الا اذا في اذا كان
في شغل ولا كان في عمل نبي نحضر عمل ولا
ويا شعراء ولا ويا ملحنين يكون هناك في
عنده تحفظه
ويعني
انسان هذه هذه طبيعه اللي تسمعها بالشريط
واللي تسمعونها اغانيها شخصيته ما فيها
تصنع ولا فيها تلون يعني
اسال بانه اليوم
انه يعني في حوالي في هذا المكتب كنت
دائما موجودين بعض لكن خليني انا على
المستوى الشخصي ايضا اعرف عبد الكريم عبد
القادر هذا الفنان كلمتين يا حبيب عمري يا
حبيب قلبي دائما
يكررها في حديثه معك هالدرجه كان رومانسي
بالفعل ولا انه والله هذه ينم على شيء من
داخله حتى في اختياره الكلمات يتدخل
بتغيير الكلمات خالد
[موسيقى]
طبعا عادل يعني انت مثل ما قلت يا حبيب
قلبي ويا حبيب عمري لانه انسان يعادل
انسان مخلوق من من
اسمها يعني انسان من اسمه ما في تصنع اكيد
بالنسبه لا انت تشتغل تشتغل وياه عبد
الكريم عبد القادر ترى عبد الكريم عبد
القادر تشتغل وياه مو اي واحد يقدر يشتغل
وياه عبد القادر انت اذا تبي تقدم نصك له
انت تتعب تتعب عبد الكريم
يعني الشاعر اللي ما يقدر يواصل ويا عبد
الكريم يتعب لانه
حريص حريص
وثانيا عادل لازم اذا خلص
واعتمد النص وهو يكتب بايده عشان اذا
بيروح يركب صوته وهو يكون كاتبه على خط
ايده اذا كتب كتب النص على خط ايده اعرف
انه اعتمده
وكذلك الالحان مو انت اللي هل الحان هذا
الصوت الشديد والصوت ترى ترى يمر في في
مراحل كثيره على ما يطلع للناس عنده
طيب
يسالك عن اكثر من نقطه بدايه حبيت لو هيك
عندي شويه فضول اعرف هل في اشياء احنا
استاذ خالد ما بنعرفها عن الفنان الراحل
الكبير هيك لو تعطينا معلومات يعني
العوام لا ما بيعرفوها وحبيت كمان اسالك
عن كيف استطاع انه يواكب تغير الذوق العام
سواء كان العربي او الخليجي او الكويتي
فيما يتعلق
الموسيقى والاغاني من زمن الزمن الكلاسيكي
الى الزمن المعاصر
[موسيقى]
يعني انا بقول لك شيء عنه يعني الله يذكره
بالخير امس المستشار تركيا للشيخ قال كل
ما في في مداخله في تلفزيون الكويت قال
عبد الكريم عبد القادر عزيز نفس وفعلا
واللي قاله مع المستشار التركي هذا الناس
اللي ما تعرفه انه جميع العروض تجي وجميع
يعني المبالغ والماده تجيه هذا الشيء
المهم اللي لازم يعرفونه الناس انه يقدم
رساله مثل ما قلتي اختي مثل ما قال اخوي
عادل انه هو قال لكم انه هاوي مو محترف
للفن
يعني بالنسبه للموسيقى وهو يعني
رائد من رواد الفن العربي ورمز من رموز
الفن الكويتي يعني احنا في في رحيله راح
يكون هناك فراغ كبير
بالساحه
الكويتيه والساحه الخليجيه لانه لو تدري
وتدرون شنو
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي شنو صار فيها لحد
اليوم لحد الساعه هذه يعني شيء مهول شيء
ما يعني انا اول مره اشوف بحياتي يعني
شو نقول نقول احنا بالاخير يعني يعني
الواحد ما يطلب له المغفره
يعني احنا بشاعر خالد البذال شاكرين لك
فقط نؤكد بانهم يعني المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ في تغريده حتى قال بانه كان من
المفترض انه يعني تكريم فنان الفنان عبد
الكريم عبد القادر يكون في شهر اكتوبر او
حتى نوفمبر وكان بصدد الاتفاق مع ابن خالد
وترتيب هذه الامور لكن القدر كان اسرع في
كلمتي ولربما اكيد ستكون ليله مختلفه من
هذه الليالي التي يكرم فيها الفنان خالد
يعني راح يبقى معانا بذكرياتنا راح يبقى
معانا بكل
اغنيه تذكرنا
بالابيض والاسود بالالوان وحتى الان شكرا
جزيلا للشاعر خالد البدال من الكويت يعطيك
الف عافيه زوار تسالمنا تعارفنا جرحنا شوق
بالزوار منذ هذه الاغنيه اغنيه زوار التي
صدرت في عام 1968 بدا عبد الكريم عبد
القادر يرسم ملامح شخصيه الغنائيه التي
اطلت خلال سنوات طويله
وتعاون مع كبار الشعراء وملحني الخليج
وطبعا على مدى سته عقود مشاهدينا عفوا قدم
الفنان الراحل مئات الاغاني منها جمر
الوداع شخبارك اني الاوان الحنين وين مرسى
لقب بالصوت الجريح الذي كسبه بعد البومه
الذي حمل نفس الاسم عام
1988 كان مناسبا بشكل كامل لطابع اغنياته
ورقتها عدوقتها التي انفردت
صوت اجيال متلاحقه احبت اعماله
وتناقلت هذه الاعمال بل عشقتها بالفعل
ليحمل 2022
وهذا العام حمل اخر اعمال الفنان الكويتيه
الكبير يعني العام الماضي طبعا مع البوم
اخير حمل عنوان انسي الحليم والذي حقق
نجاحا ملفتا حين صدوره معنى الان مشاهدينا
من الكويت الملحن انور عبد الله اهلا بك
استاذ انور معنا طبعا تعازينا الحاره في
فقدان الراحل الكبير
ودت له وابدا معك بالحديث عن الحان اغاني
التي تخطط حتى حدود الكويت وحدود الخليج
الى العالم العربي على مدى هذه المسيره
الفنيه الطويله ما الذي كان يميزها حتى
استطاعت ان تصل الى الجميع
صباح الخير وصباح الخير لمشاهده العربيه
نعزي
[موسيقى]
ولكن عبد الكريم ابتدا مع عبد الرحمن
البعيجان
فنان ناشئ وملحن نشط فعمل معاه تكون ظالم
يعني الزوار بعدين
لكن بدايته وانتشاره في تكون ظالم نجحت
نجاح كبير وما كرر هذا اللون من الاغاني
ما كرره بتاتا عملها بس بعد الاغنيه هذه
ومن ثم عمل الاستاذ احمد باقر الليل يا
قمرنا وانا جيت في سهرنا وبعدين استمر مع
عبد الرحمن البعيجان ما يمنع انه اخذ مثلا
من مصطفى العوضي لحن من ابراهيم الصوله
لحن من سعود الراشد لحن هذيل اسال حان
فرديه شذي بس ولكن ما عاد البيجان الى ان
طلع فنان جديد اسمه عبد الرب ادريس كان
وقتها ابو عادل دكتور عبد الله
العمر
توه متخرج من المعهد وفنان شاب ونشط
فالتقى معاه عن طريق الشاعر عبد اللطيف
البنايه وعملوا اغنيه
اول اغنيه طبعا اللي عاشق الصبر يطول
لم نجحه يتعاشك مسك عبد الكريم في عبد
الرب ادريس واشتغل معه قال هذا الان
الحصان الجديد اللي يركض بالساحه فعمل معه
غريب واعترف لك وباختصار مجموعه من
الاغاني بعدها طلع راشد الخضر رحمه الله
عليه توام متخرج من المعهد فنان شاب وكذلك
عن طريق عبد اللطيف البناي كذلك ما ننسى
في حياه عبد القادر على طول جماعها مع بعض
وعملوا حبيبي يزعل من الصبر اخر ومجموعه
الاغاني الجميله هذه حلوه في هذه الفتره
طلع انور عبد الله متخرج من المعهد
واجتمعنا مع انا معاه في اغنيه
وانا اذكر موقف الى الان يمكن ما قلته في
كل مقاباتي عبد القادر اول اغنيه وهي
اغنيه رياضيه
لنادي الخليج في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
كان وقتها فايز في كاس اليد عبد اللطيف
البناي قال له والله في يوم الاحد نسمع
انور توه طالع كذا كذا خل نشتغل فقال اوكي
فقعدنا مع
بعضيه قال لي ابو عبد الله كيف الحال حياك
الله وكذا هذا انا بسمع اللحن عجبني غنيته
ما عجبني انا اعتذر من الان وهي اغنيه
رياضيه وفعلا سمعت اللحن وقال يلا خلنا
نسجل يعني شنو الاستديو شافني انا مرتبك
ايه
وشافني انا مرتبك ليش لانه قدامي هامه
كبيره
هرم من اهرامات على الاغنيه الخليجيه وانا
ملحد توني في بدايتي في بدايه طريقي
فقال استاذ انور والله ما فيني شيء قلت كل
ما اقول شيء اغني تقول حلو كل ما اقول شيء
تقول حلو ما عندك ملاحظات كلام ما عندي
ملاحظه على مرتبك
انا اقولك من البدايه
والله العظيم
احنا في الاستوديو انت الاستاذ
وانا المطرب فانا اتلقى توجيهاتك شنو اللي
تقول انا شوف شوف الموقف من الفنان الكبير
وابتدينا في هذه الاغنيه
الرياضيه ومن ثم انتقلنا الى اغنيه الى
مين الشيخ محمد بن راشد ال مكتوم ومن ثم
بدينا في محاله
واستمرت الاغاني هذه الى الحمد لله لي
الشرف وهذا وسام على صدري انا احطه اني
انا لحنت له 45 اغنيه
اعتبر اكثر ملحن في حياه عبد الكريم عبد
القادر
يعني احنا خلينا نقول بانه انور عبد الله
علاقتك مختلفه مع مع الفنان عبد الكريم
عبد القادر ابي اقول في في السنوات
الاخيره
عبد الكريم ليش ما يطلع على المسرح شو
اللي يخليه مبتعد عن المسرح
عبد الكريم من زمان ما طلع المسرح
والسبه يعني كذا موقف صار
باختصار بعد عبد الكريم ما يحب الاوامر
عبد الكريم ما يحب واحد ايوه ما يحب واحد
يقول يلا غني يلا وقف خلفان يغني بعدين
انت غني ما يحب شذي بعدين عبد الكريم ما
يحب السهر وبعدين عبد الكريم فنان حساس
الى ابعد الحدود ما ممكن تتصور شلون ابو
خالد حساس جدا جدا وحليم لكن من داخله
يغلي ولكن ما يبين لك ولا اشي بتاتا انت
لما تقعد في حفلات سواء حفلات عامه ولا
حفلات اجتماعيه وكذا مثلا يلا غني يلا غني
اغنيه كذا كذا
ما احب شذي بعدين ما يحب وهو يغني في
الحفلات ناس يقومون يرقصون ولا كذا مدري
شنو ما يحب اذا هو يغني بهذا القرار رحمه
الله انه يبتعد عن الحفل شكرا للملحن انور
عبد الله ابو عبد الله شكرا جزيلا لك
واعلم هذه المحبه الصادقه في كلماتك
ومشاعرك شكرا جزي لا للملحن انور عبد الله
قبل ثمانيه اشهر تعرض المطرب الراحل عبد
الكريم عبد القادر لوعكه صحيه اضطر وقتها
الى ان يجري جراحه في القلب
ظهر بعدها مشاهدينا وطمان ج على صحته لكن
ازمته الصحيه الاخيره ادت الى رحيله باحدى
مستشفيات الكويت شيعه جثمان الصوت الجريح
الى مثواه الاخير في مقبره الصليبيخات في
الكويت وكان في صاله العزاء حشود كبيره من
الاسره والاصدقاء والمحبين
من العربيه صباح العربيه تحديدا مشاهدينا
كانت
هنا بعض اللقاءات مع نجوم الفن الكويتيين
فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
الاغنيه الاجتماعيه وافتقدوا محبين على
المستوى المحلي وعلى مستوى الخليجي
والعربي كان نموذج للفن الراقي وتعامله
واخلاقه كان بيني وبينه تواصل في واحد
خمسه
الفين
لما احنا درينا انه هو في المستشفى طبعا
وتعبان فطلب من عندنا عدم نشر اي شيء
علشان ما يعني يضيق خلق الشعب الكويتي
وقال رحمه الله عليه اذا رده وطلع من
المستشفى راح يكون اهو راح يعني
يتكلم بهذا الامر ويشكر كل من يسال عنه
[موسيقى]
من الكويت ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف الفنان
طارق العلي طارق صبحك الله بالخير يعني
اعزائنا للشعب الكويتي
لكل محبي الفنان عبد الكريم عبد القادر
اليوم لما الناس تعرف الكويت تقول والله
الابراج عبد الكريم عبد القادر وغيره من
الامور اذا هو داله على الكويت بهذا الصوت
هذه هذه الميزه اللي يكسبها فنان بانه
يكون وجه لبلاده ما الذي يعني
السلام عليكم صبحكم الله بالخير
وعظم الله اجرنا واجركم وكل محب لهذا
الفنان الكبير عبد الكريم عبد القادر
ونسال الله سبحانه وتعالى اللهم امين الله
يرحمه ويغفر له ويسكنه فسيح جناته ويلهم
اهله الصبر والسلوان
الحقيقه يعني اسم مثل عبد الكريم عبد
القادر مثل ما تفضلوا كثير من الاسماء
الكبيره الفنانين والفنانات في مجال بناء
حتى في مجال في كل مجال عبد الكريم
يتذكرني في توفى عمي عبد الحليم عبد الرضا
الكل اجمع على محبته
ويتغنى باعماله الفنيه الجميله ايضا عبد
الكريم عبد القادر من الاسماء الكبيره
الكويتيه الوطنيه اللي نتذكر دائما وطني
النهار هذا النهار الجليل اللي تغنى فيه
دوله الكويت
عبد الكريم عبد القادر
بفضل الله الصنع اللي هذا الاسم
احترام كبير محبه كبيره وارتبط فيه الصغير
والكبير هو ارتبط فيه حتى في مشاعرك انسان
على اليوم لما اسمع عبد الكريم عبد القادر
اعيش مع الحاله اللي يغنيها واتذكر حتى
حياتي الخاصه
المشاعر
الرياضه اليوم انا كرياضي متعصب اذا كان
بياضبه نتذكر بسم الله
وبدايه السماد
الاغاني الوطنيه
والاجتماعيه
له بصمه في كل مجال وفي وجدان يعني كل
كويتي وخليجي حتى لو كان مهتم بشتى وعربي
طبعا بشتى المجالات
الجميع اجمع على قديش كان احساسه مرهف
وقديه كان رومانسي اللافت بالنسبه الي انه
استطاع انه يحافظ على هذا هاي الرومانسيه
وهذه الحساسيه على مدى عقود طويله يعني ما
كانت مرتبطه بسن شبابه مثلا او بحاله هو
كان بيمر فيها ولكن مرتبطه بروحه وبشخصيته
هو كانسان
شوفوا طال عمرك
الزمن اللي هم عاشوا فيه ايضا
زمن الكلمه
حتى الان في كلمات جميله
واسماء كريمه كبيره تغني في في عصر لكن
جيلهم جيل المعاناه جيلهم جيل صعب انك انه
حتى تقرا اسرتك انك تغني ولا ايضا جيل عاش
المشاعر الاشياء يعني
ايضا الجيل الانسان الخلوق ولا انتم كلكم
ما عليك زود ابو محمد
ابو محمد طارق يعني انا ودي اسال انا شفت
لك فيديو بالطياره مع عبد الكريم عبد
القادر في اغنيه ما نسينا وقاعد يبتسم
وانت تغنيها معاه كلمني عن هذا الانسان
شلون كان انا ادري لكن كلم المشاهد اليوم
اللي ما يعرفه
عبد الكريم عبد القادر دائما
الابتسامه
فانا دائما اضحك طبعا
اصدقاء الخاصين استاذ خالد
27 سنه صديق لك هذا الشاب
الكويتي ايضا صديقه واحنا خاصه خاصه
[موسيقى]
المستشار تركي ال الشيخ وفي مناسبه من
المناسبات في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الغالي على قلوبنا حفظه الله حوض خليجنا
ان شاء الله الامه العربيه كلها
فقاعد اقول حق خالد
فهو يضحك انا طبعا انتم عارفين كراسي
الطيران
قاعد اقول انا احب واحد
يكون جنب بعض وهو يضحك يقول وانا احبك
وانا
يا حبيب عمري
هذي كلمه
ايه
طارق العلي شكرا جزيلا يمكن الوقت هو اللي
حرمنا من انك تكمل هذه
المعلومه وشكرا جزيلا لمشاركتك ويانا شكرا
ايضا للملحنه انور عبد الله ايضا الشاعر
خالد البذات شكرا لعبد الكريم عبد القادر
اللي ترك لنا هذا الاثر الكبير ترك لنا
هذا الارث اللي يبقى معنا رحمه الله عليه
في كل وقت لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات